thank you sherry april is designated as
the month of the military child a time
to honor the sacrifice
from the sacrifices made by military
families worldwide
with an emphasis on the experience of
the dependent children
of military members serving at home and
overseas and today we're joined by
talitha vickers who is a news anchor and
author
of a book that is a heartwarming salute
to military men
and women and their families and welcome
to litha
it's so good to have you on the show now
you are a very successful news anchor
in north carolina but it was really your
love of books that your mom instilled in
you at a young age that inspired you to
become an author tell us a little bit
about that
thank you for having me mercedes you hit
the nail on the head my mom would always
take us to the laundromat and whenever
that happened i knew we were going on an
adventure growing up because the
laundromat
meant that we got to go to the library
and got to get
lost in all of these great books but you
know what mercedes i never really saw
anyone who looked like me in a lot of
those books
and that really was the driving force
behind creating the book
why my hero had to go and also for
my brother and my nephew my brother
served in the army too as well so i
absolutely love books i love this story
about how your nephew
inspired you to write it and it really
inspired the cover this story was not
easy to get published tell us a little
bit of what you had to deal with in
order to get it published
sure and i if i could just hold up the
book here it's why my hero had to go and
you know it's beautifully illustrated by
keith hogggood and the book
you know has my nephew on the cover and
when i started you know shopping it
around to different publishing houses
they said wow this is a great story
we've never seen
a story quite like this but could you
lighten his skin
for a broader appeal we think that would
have a broader appeal so more people
will buy this story and buy
into it and it would be more universal
and for me i was like
this is universal this is my my son
my excuse me my nephew and my son they
look just like this little boy
and so that really um i got a pit in my
stomach to be honest mercedes when i was
told that and i said you know what
there's nothing like this out there in
the market
i'm going to do it myself i'm going to
do it my way because i know
that whether there's a black child on
the cover a spanish child on the cover
i mean an asian child on the cover this
is a story that resonates with everyone
you and i both know we always see those
stories on the news about those big
surprise
return homecomings right but it's the
story behind that
that this goes into i'm a little bit
deeper to pull back those layers so i
didn't care
um i i wanted to make sure that yes
my nephew was represented but there are
other books in the works i don't care
who's on the cover it's the story
behind it you know and i'm not going to
change the skin absolutely there's 1.2
million military children of active duty
members worldwide and representation
it does matter now tell us where can we
get
the book well the book i'm happy to
announce is
available on my website
talipavickers.com it's also
got picked up by barnes noble amazon
as well and you can also take it with
you on the go because it's an e-book too
as well
that it looks so great we have nellis
air force base here in las vegas i'm
sure
so many families could relate to the
story and again what an inspiring book
thank you for pushing for representation
because like i said it does matter
thank you so much talitha jc over to you